[Music]
no no please stop stop I'm so you don't
have to do
this please stop hey what are you doing
man you scared her off hey that's your
fault oh it's my fault okay I'm not the
guy with a deep dish pepperoni pizza for
a face okay I know I know it just seems
like every time I try to get close to a
girl I end up scaring them away I don't
know what I'm doing wrong here don't say
that yeah you're so money Freddy I'm
grasping at straws here I tried the Hat
I thought that was good addition I know
I got some holes in the sweater but it's
a cashmere I'm not going to throw that
away you like it or not literally you're
the guy of every girl's dreams are the
knife hands a bit much KN hands might be
ton back of the knife hands maybe knife
thumb knife thumb could be K knife thumb
that could work I like the we you're
thinking hey pound it pound it Budd get
all up in that all
right well I'm getting ready to watch a
video oh really what oh just a scary
movie do you like scary movies because
personally not really for me I'm going
to be honest I don't like scary movies
I'm more of romance guy oh and it takes
a real man to admit that I love romcoms
I cried during the notebook oh who
didn't oh the way he kisses her in the
rain classic scene classic I'd actually
switch teams for Ryan Gosling and I feel
very secure sa as you should and that
that's actually the least gay thing I've
heard you say all night so hey you sound
cute hey what are you doing on Saturday
night
[Music]
um if we could if we could just cut it
on the scream and I understand too I I
scream myself sometimes I wake up in the
morning and of screaming myself cuz I'm
like what the hell am I looking at with
a mirror I you're not the first this way
you should have seen Jenny Nelson eighth
grade Spring Fling when I asked her the
day you should have seen her face it
went green oh oh greener than me green
greener than my face yeah and that's
tough to do very hard to do very hard to
do but listen I've gotten a lot better
at ladies since then I know what you
guys are into little white wine little
Vanity Fair this is going there what are
you talking about hey I think she's into
you oh really oh she likes me which part
the two bolts in my head the fact I'm
technically a dead gu come on but let's
pump the brakes I'm I'm a monster you're
not a monster no no technically though
I'm a monster right okay you're you're a
monster but you're one of the good
monsters butd thanks I'll take
[Music]
it
he